when i was a kid i i was i was fortunate  that my parents were uh great movie  lovers and they would  um  we lived outside of new york city but at  that time when movies opened they would  first open and  in  one theater or two theaters at a time  and so if you wanted to go see a movie  it's opening weekend you went into it  was almost like going to the theater you  went into manhattan i saw almost  all of the  you know seminal movies of the  early mid-1970s  2001 a space odyssey and blazing saddles  and  annie hall and all of these films uh uh  in that way taking the journey into  manhattan waiting in line anticipating  the screening  going to it the french connection  these are films that i was i was likely  way too young to be seeing  given that i was not  you know i didn't meet up to the r  rating at the time in terms of my age  but  i was dazzled by the experience